This video is sponsored by Fica Swath
cleanse.
When I was little,
I spent hours upon hours playing video
games like Rome through the war,
age of empires and by the full middle
earth.
If you had a similar childhood as mine,
you will love faking since its latest
update.
The game is bigger than ever with nation
to nation Bedell's within fucking sure
have to ability to choose your own place
town.
Either build a strong economy,
focused on fighting wars or rain.
Your empire faking since now reached
over 20 million players so installed the
game,
clicking my link in the description
below and you'll get 200 gold and an
initial protection shoots for free.
Why would you choose slide
one of the most iconic opening scenes
instead of Danny Boyle's 90 96 movie,
trainspotting in managers to take
something that is unrelatable for most
of us,
the destructive and self destructive
behavior of drug addicts and draws us in
with a rationalization.
We can all on the stands.
She was diy in one time.
You the fuck you on a Sunday morning to
sitting on the couch watching my numbing
spit at Kachin game shorts,
stuffing,
fucking jumped for it and I chose not to
choose life.
I choose something else and the reasons,
but I'm the reasons.
These reasons when you've got hat on,
we are all aware of the mundanity,
your flavor of [inaudible].
What can I get stuck in the boring daily
responsibilities while it has to attend
to choose cleaning your house too is
doing Texas two is going through the
same job every day from nine to five but
why would you choose that?
Why not just choose pleasure,
especially if the pleasure.
Take the backstory guys,
I'm you ever had multiply it by 2000 and
there still are nowhere near it.
Rent and then his friends therefore find
themselves in a similar position as I
argued,
similar dosing,
the lion king,
the position of choosing escapism that
pleasure over adopting responsibility.
Birth where Simba chooses eating bugs,
relaxing and singing over reclaiming his
kingdom rent and his friends to a darker
and more destructive substance in order
to escape the boring identity of normal,
lower to middle class life.
The film then exposes another hypocrisy
about looking down on the heroin
addiction
without poisoned my body.
Whether I should.
All the fucking chemicals
move fucking weed.
It's always the life mine.
Is it in your body but shaped
cause own to all addicted to something.
Does it really make any difference if we
choose heroin or if you choose alcohol,
violence or smoking?
If we choose benching,
television and movies,
instagram or twitter,
choose facebook,
twitter,
snapchat,
instagram and oppose and other ways to
spew your bail cross.
People you've never met.
Choose updating your profile.
Tell the world what you had for
breakfast and hope that someone
somewhere cares.
The answer to transplanting a guesthouse
is that yes,
it does make a difference cause just as
rent and says,
this was to be my final head,
but let's be clear by this.
That's final pets and final heads
there.
Our addictions and our addictions.
Maybe you are all escaping something
trying to fill a void because although
good addiction can do that,
the ones we choose,
we will have an impact on our lives.
There are addictions,
there's will bring us up addictions that
will bring us down slowly and addictions
that he'll bring us down.
False drove to film the pleasure of how
to escape the boredom and identity and
the harshness of life.
Seeing strengthen,
deepen hell almost destroying himself
and everything around him.
The ending of the film then leaves us
with this message.
It is better to choose to responsibility
often normal mundane life than to seek
further into the hell that escape
displeasure creates.
Think I'm going to be just like you.
The job family,
the fucking big television,
the washing machine,
the car,
the compact desk and electrical,
10 Elkanah,
good health,
low cholesterol,
dental insurance,
mortgage starter,
home leisure wear,
luggage,
three piece,
suite diy gave him shorts,
junk food,
children walks in the park,
the nine to five good at goal washing
the car choices,
but it is not the solution and this is
what the secret of transporting tea two
offers to me.
What makes this film that was critiques
for Wallowing in its own nostalgia.
A brilliant film is that it's complete
so question not fully answered by the
original cause.
What happens where you choose life when
you choose getting away.
We've tried to adopt your
responsibilities and irritating that's
comes with it when you moved from in the
escape,
his position to Waldorf adopting a
normal Monday life where I will leave
you 20 years later choose life,
but as even bremmer a deck to play spot
states.
Life doesn't come for free.
That will be beautiful moments,
but it will also leave you scarred.
The sequel explores this question is a
good step to replace her addiction to
heroin with an addiction to running and
addiction to getting away good.
It won't feel the void.
What'd you channel on
getting away?
Choosing life will work out the way you
hoped.
Truest disappointment.
Choose fill dreams filled and and answer
the questions.
Settle for less and keep a brave face on
it.
Choose disappointment and choose losing
the ones you love.
Donuts.
They fold from view a piece of you dies
with them until you can see that one day
in the future,
piece by piece they will all be gone and
there'll be nothing left of you to call
alive or dead.
Choose your future Veronica,
choose life
and then it is time to return home and
see what you left behind your heroin
addiction.
Yes,
but maybe,
maybe something more
so what you been up to for 20 years
cause maybe you miss something maybe
within the hell threatens heroin,
addiction,
care,
escapism.
There was something more worth not music
away from something else was choosing
and death I think is the lesson.
Trees.
Putting explorers where we choose to be
addicted to the moving forwards.
We forget to look back and more
importantly we forget to be where we are
when there's nowhere to move forward to
anymore renting us no choice but to look
back and realize he mistakes,
things that he didn't appreciate when he
was experiencing the lesson in this
nostalgic film.
This film that is about one that's been
well does be lost.
Having this one on day,
sunny afternoon,
two young minds up to Kevin for our very
first hand offs.
Warning.
All right.
Fresh bag.
Your hand is that baby.
Don't just choose your future.
Choose to not choose to be present.
Choose to experience the movies with
your friends.
Choose the lofter.
Say,
choose the one that got away.
Choose to be tooth to sometimes that
still listen to the user.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you all for watching.
So to to moving to a new place and
working from my laptop and dealing with
some internet issues.
I struggled with some of the audio
mixing birth.
Let me know what you think in the
comments below.
Support our channel by installing the
game vikings with Lincoln and
description below.
You can also tip us over paypal or
suppose on Patrion to unlock some
awesome additional content.
Get some extra stickers and excess our
discord channel.
Check out my lion king video if you
haven't because it was blocked,
but it was later released by Disney.
So many of our subscribers haven't seen
it.
And thank you to our top tier patrons
and we will see you the next time.